That is a wrap on season 2 of the witcher it is
hard to believe it's been over a year since we
kicked off this season in typical witcher fashion
in a freezing cold forest in the middle of the
night since then we've shot for 158 days with at
least one unit sometimes two sometimes three all
while decked out in face shields and face masks
and goggles and slathered in hand sanitizer we
shot in 15 locations with 89 cast members and over
1200 different crew members all bringing their
craft to life none of us has ever experienced a
television season like this before i'm sure we
cannot wait to show you what geralt and Ciri and
yennefer and jaskir and all of your favorites have
been up to since we left them at the battle of
saturn hill there are plenty of new characters and
story lines and of course monsters to explore as
well as we dig into the blood of elves and beyond
we are so proud of everything we accomplished in
season 2 and we can't wait for you to watch it
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my brand
new witcher season 2 teaser trailer netflix just
dropped some brand new footage they crammed a
whole bunch of easter eggs in here so we'll break
it all down if you're brand new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos if you
didn't know the good news is the witcher season
2 episodes will premiere this year before the end
of the year probably not till december but we're
still getting it this year of course i'll be doing
videos for all the episodes there's also a special
convention that they're doing just for the witcher
netflix is putting on a convention that'll involve
both witcher video game stuff from cd projekt red
and witcher netflix tv series stuff on july 9th
that's why they have both versions of geralt
here the henry cavill version and the video game
version i don't know if they have any plans to
announce any witcher video game stuff there's been
so much talk and theories about them doing the
witcher 4 video game sequel ever since the witcher
3 came out the studio has made it sound like
they're not planning on doing that for a long long
time but eventually they'll get around to making
a big triple a witcher game but the best theory
is is that the next video game the next big one
would follow Ciri just because of the way they end
geralt's story during the witcher 3. the witcher
netflix series is really only following the books
with a few borrowed things from the games the
game story actually picks up after the end of the
last book but there is some stuff that you'll see
in the tv series especially during season 2 like
the wild hunt they are doing the wild hunt during
season 2 that'll seem familiar to the video games
but the way they're doing the wild times i'll
explain it's a little bit different it's not quite
what you expect but the way they cut this teaser
trailer they just quick cut through a whole bunch
of different shots they just cram a ton of easter
eggs into this if you didn't know though season
2 will adapt blood of elves the next book in the
series the title is a reference to Ciri and her
elder blood she literally has the blood of elves
in her and that's where the elder blood comes
from so just starting at the beginning of the
footage here i'll just go through shot by shot
as you can probably tell based on where geralt
and Ciri were heading at the end of the witcher
season 1 geralt was getting ready to take her
back to kara morin because it would be easier to
keep her safe there because it's a fortified keep
but also because it's a place of learning a home
of the witcher school the wolf where he himself
was raised and trained to become a witcher there
were a couple flashbacks during season one where
you kind of see his beginnings there where you see
his mother eventually take him and leave him there
at the school of the wolf but the keep itself is
a center of knowledge it's meant to be a school
like it's literally called the school of the wolf
but eventually geralt starts to figure out what's
happening with her based on what he learns in
sintra during the fall of sintra and because he
witnessed what happened with her mother pavetta
and her father duney they actually do have some
easter eggs for them duney and pavetta during this
teaser trailer as well you probably recognize the
way they cut some of the footage the elder blood
itself makes her the most powerful character on
the show though more powerful than ariden in the
wild hunt that you see in all the video games
and everyone in the world of the witcher every
major faction both good and evil all want to use
her power for themselves use her either as a tool
or just straight up kill her and literally take
her power like airden in the wild hunt so that's
the big reason for taking her back to care morin
she just has no idea how to use her abilities
right now so she's incredibly vulnerable and
all that power doesn't matter if you don't know
how to use it but you do actually see her use it
during season one instinctively to protect herself
at the end of the season she winds up exploding
all those men like a bunch of wet balloons as you
probably know there aren't any more new witchers
being created not because they don't want to but
because they no longer have the means or knowledge
to create the special potions that give the people
the witcher mutations the actual trial the grasses
there was a big massacre there that they'll
probably cover in either some of the tie-in
material or some of the spin-off series that
they're doing there's so many witcher spin-off
series that they're doing they're doing a witcher
movie called the nightmare of the wolf about young
vesemir they're doing the witcher blood origin
which is a prequel series about the first witcher
a thousand years ago Ciri is trained as a witcher
by geralt vesemir who will meet during season 2
with the help of tris lambert eskel also going
to be season 2 characters so she kind of becomes
a witcher of sorts but she can't undergo the
mutations so technically she's not a real witcher
but she does act in the capacity of a witcher
during the events of the games later in her life
the whole idea with this version of Ciri during
season 2 though obviously much younger she's still
a teenager at this point in her life so that's why
most of this new witcher season 2 teaser trailer
focuses on foreshadowing her learning more about
herself more about her elder blood powers more
about the witchers in general the school of the
wolf and her actual training in witcher lore and
fighting techniques this is basically meant to be
a Ciri trailer even though geralt does appear in
it you might have wondered why you don't see
henry cavill's face appear during a lot of
this quick cut footage you actually do see him in
this it's just that he's barely standing in frame
geralt's main mission though his whole purpose
for existing at the moment in addition to just
generally being a witcher is to protect her so
part of that is helping teach her to fight so that
she can defend herself like actual practical
fight training with a sword geralt himself
isn't an expert in the lore of elder blood now
like he practices a little bit of magic witchers
use special signs basic magic spells to enhance
some of their attacks or protect them based on
whatever it is they need to do it's a much simpler
form of magic than what you see practiced by
actual mages like yennefer much more powerful
magics or the magic that Ciri is capable of the
big advantage that Ciri has is that not only does
she learn how to use a lot of the basic skills and
abilities that witchers have but because of her
elder blood she's also a source which is what you
call someone who has magical affinity in the world
of the witcher when a really powerful source like
yennefer for instance is discovered usually they
wind up going to the school of mages and trained
as a traditional mage but Ciri for instance is
mostly trained as a witcher but the elder blood
gives Ciri even more magical power than all the
other traditional mages on the show or in the
books it's just that she would actually have to
learn how to cast all that magic she could do some
of it instinctively but she can become way more
powerful if she actually read a lot of these magic
books and learn these spells vesemir who's being
played by kim bonya from killing eve this actor
here you might recognize him he stays back at the
school the wolf mostly because he's just gotten so
old that he's long since transitioned to more of
a professorial role more of a teacher but because
they're not taking new students during present
day there's nobody for him to teach so most of
his time is just spent trying to fix the keep
which is slowly falling apart over the centuries
they really didn't get into the history of the
witchers that much during season one or even the
history of care morin but i think that's just
because they're saving it for season 2 when we
actually go there like here's this ancient place
that's also very important and they'll just teach
the audience about they'll teach us about it as
Ciri learns about it because she's becoming a much
bigger point of view character during season
2 way bigger than she was during season one
yes the show is called the witcher and that's
mostly a reference to geralt but really if you
read the books you realize that Ciri is actually
the most important character at least the way the
narrative treats her so a lot of these images in
the trailer are just meant to be general day to
day of her learning things slowly and training
like the first one here is of her in the woods
on the way to the keep with geralt the next one
seems like her starting to learn more about the
making of witcher potions like even though you
saw geralt using potions a little during season 1
geralt has to make all those potions himself so as
a witcher when you're trained to be a witcher you
have to be well versed in potion lore this image
of the desk with the tools is just more of that
inside the keep more studying in the practical
arts and knowledge necessary to become a witcher
this image with a hand in the robes the rings
the ornate necklace might either be tris at the
school of the wolf or it could be from yennefer's
storyline remember at the beginning of season 2
yennefer has been captured by nilfgaard as the end
of season one that big battle so she is forced to
serve emperor emhyr the nilfgaardians and work
amongst the other mages that are serving him
but eventually geralt yennefer and Ciri will be
reunited it just won't happen at the beginning
of season 2. yes gear is also back during season 2
but he's not with geralt or Ciri at the beginning
of the season either this is just Ciri inside
the armory of the keep you could probably see
the engravings on the witcher swords here Ciri
eventually does get a witcher sword given to
her by geralt after she finishes her training
it's called zireael which also means swallow the
reason why they call the sword that is because
it's Ciri's true name in the elder speech her
name is zireael so her standing amidst all
these witcher swords with these engravings
is meant to foreshadow that when she says in
the trailer that she needs to understand in
the images flash of that red cloak on the ground
the human heart and then the two figures dancing
that's just a reference to her understanding her
heritage the line of her family that passed down
the elder blood the relationship of her parents
duney and pavetta they kind of just teased that
during season one but that's who these two dancing
figures are meant to be duney and pavetta this is
more of her just running around the keep at night
in the snow having a little bit of fun this image
of the man fighting the monster seems like
it's just a painting inside the keep depicting
ancient witchers fighting monsters here she's
still standing on the road on the way to the
keep and the voice that speaks danger might
be eskel lambert or one of the other witchers
this is just one of the ancient daggers that
they have inside the keep this is geralt and
Ciri again still on the road to karen moran you
can see geralt kind of standing halfway in frame
then you see Ciri walking around the ruins
of the keep some parts of it have fallen into
extreme disrepair but the voices crying out in the
background yelling seem like it's more of Ciri or
girl dreaming or having visions about the white
frost in the wild hunt just more foreshadowing
for the really big story later on the white frost
is probably one of the biggest cataclysmic events
that they talk about is the whole reason why the
elder blood exists in the first place that Ciri
possesses the original elves that lived on the
main world of the witcher here where geralt and
syria live thousands of years ago learned about
this potential coming of the white frost it's
meant to be this ice age this big cataclysmic
event that will wipe out all life on the planet
so this ancient group of elves sought to create a
being of their race with enough magical power to
stop it using a very selective breeding process
and genetic programs eventually they wind up
traveling to another world and that's where eredin
the leader of the wild hunt comes from he comes
from this ancient order of elves that created
the elder blood so there are a couple important
reasons why the wild hunt travel around the
multiverse to different worlds if you didn't know
obviously the witcher seems like a fantasy story
but really it's more of a science fiction story
because there's a multiverse people travel between
worlds all the time the wild hunt is just one of
those groups that's able to travel between worlds
of the multiverse so we'll see how they treat them
this early in the story and it'll probably just be
visions and dreams that people get like Ciri gets
they are referenced in some of the book stuff that
they're doing right now on the show but you don't
actually see them like legit come into the story
until much later on there's a whole bunch more
footage here of Ciri just getting her ass kicked
all over the place during her training running
around in the woods nearby exploring the darker
places inside the keep just being really curious
around the school of the wolf they also said that
they fixed the nilfgaardian armor that everyone
hated so much during season 1 the big ballsack
armor but the only other big character that we
know about that they're doing during season 2
that you don't really see during any of this
teaser trailer footage is rience from the books
he's one of the main antagonists during blood
of elves the book that they're doing for season
2 but he's really only an underling serving a
bigger villain who you've actually already met
on the show during season one but will probably
happen is is that that witcher convention that
netflix is doing in july we'll probably get
a bigger teaser trailer so i'll do a new easter
eggs video for that while you wait for everything
click here for my full marvel loki episode
1 video and click here for my loki episode 2
trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!